did you know that babies are transphobic
i actually did know that babies are
transphobic
but i have had this point reinforced by
libs of tick tock my favorite twitter
account one of my favorite twitter
accounts
and a viral video that's going around
tick tock right now
i've talked about the transphobic baby
at work before
um i went in a room with him today and i
had my wig on which i took off dao
because it's
like nine o'clock at night um
he didn't cry
and he was like
babbling at me
and i had to look at him and like
do you like me now because
we've
had a moment or do you like me now
because i have long hair and look more
feminine because then you're more
transphobic
and then he started to cry so that was
my answer
i
truly do not know if this is satire or
not
i don't know i could see it be 100 being
a joke
and i could 100 see this being real and
i don't know because our society is
completely through the looking glass now
and when you can be kicked out of polite
society for saying that dudes are not
chicks and chicks are not dudes then you
really don't know then then your ability
to discern between satire and reality is
is gone
but let's just take it seriously
this idea that babies are transphobic i
know a lot of conservatives have pushed
back they've said
you're calling babies transphobic
how crazy is that that's insane you
should that's not
that's not right you're saying that
babies are afraid of tr uh yeah
of course they are because they haven't
had their brains poisoned by leftism yet
so of course they they're not it's not
irrational
but yeah babies are afraid of a lot of
things
my baby's afraid when i sneeze
okay babies get scared of lots of things
and it's because they're extremely
vulnerable and so
when
dudes dress up like chicks in big crazy
costumes and babies look at that they
say something's not right there
something's a little bit off stranger
danger get me out of here that is
perfectly reasonable and makes sense and
maybe you know the left used to always
say we need to learn from the children
learn from the babies maybe we can learn
from them a little bit and say huh maybe
the baby's right maybe this isn't quite
right maybe
something is a little off here maybe we
need to
fix things
i i am not of the opinion that you know
when we're young we know everything and
then we just get corrupted
by society i don't i don't think that's
true i think that very often
young people have you know all of their
untutored desires and appetites and
emotions and that's the whole point of
education is to kind of tamp that down
and and give yourself some command over
your own liberty
but sometimes babies are more correct
than us okay and when when our minds
become so
poisoned by ideology that they divorce
themselves from reality
maybe we need to look
to the wisdom of the babes
hey man i'm glad you like that clip
you know dog
i appreciated that you watched it if you
want to get more clips i would recommend
you ring that bell subscribe get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five-star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you